إنه اندفاع كبير للأدرينالين مجرد التواجد
في الملعب ورؤية كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
تعتقد أنهم يجعلونك متوترة ، لكن
هذا يثيرك حتى عندما أتوقف عن مشاهدة
الفرقة بمجرد أن يتوقف الجميع عن النظر إلى
مباراة كرة القدم ،
فقد قطعوا الكاميرات وأعينهم كذلك
عليك تلك الأضواء تومض والكاميرات
تشاهده في الحشد يصاب بالجنون أو
أن أسلوب جاي قال إنه ليس شيئًا
تراه كل يوم اسمي
كايلا جوردون أنا قائد الصحافة
وجاي هنا في جامعة ولاية جاكسون.
لا شيء للغاية بالنسبة إلى إعداد Jay ،
يعد إعداد J أسلوبًا معقدًا ،
فهو مزيج من الألعاب البهلوانية والأسلوب الأفريقي
مع القليل من موسيقى الجاز ، ويقارننا الكثير من
الأشخاص
بالجيميز لأن لدينا الكثير من الأزرار في حركاتنا
التي  الفرق ليس لديها بعض
حركاتنا المميزة بالتأكيد ستكون
ملحًا وفلفلًا ، إنه نوع من المكان الذي
نلقي فيه ذراعينا ذهابًا وإيابًا
توقيع آخر مارس لدينا هو أطراف أصابعك
التي تسحب
حوضك ذهابًا وإيابًا وذراعيك فقط  كوم
عندما قال جاي مشيًا ،
ستشاهد وركينا يبدو
وكأنهم يجدون سخيفًا منبثقًا
وهذا نوع من الظهور
ذهابًا وإيابًا بوتيرة سريعة جدًا.
جامعة ولاية جاكسون على
طول الطريق في عام 1971 ، اسمي غلوريا تاتوم
، أنا مؤسس منظمة Alumni Jay
، وأنا أيضًا
مطبوعات أسطورية أصلية في Jason ، كانت مجموعات J
في الأصل من
الفتيات اللواتي كن يسيرن أمام
الفرقة  لكنهم عقدوا الأدوار ، كانت لدى
شيرلي ميلرتون بلاكلي ، الراعي في
ذلك الوقت بالذات ، هذه الفكرة الرائعة
لإحضار مجموعات J ليكونوا راقصين ولذا
قال جي إنه ولد ، فإن تدريبنا
وممارساتنا مختلفة عن فرق الرقص الأخرى
التي نجريها لمسافة ميلين في 18  دقائق
كل يوم نمارسه من الاثنين
إلى الجمعة ثم السبت في
اللعبة ، لذا من خلال سبعة أيام في
الأسبوع ، قال جيسون ستة من تلك الأيام البانجو
إنه تنافسي للغاية ،
لدينا تخفيضات كل أسبوع للعبة
أنت  r spot غير مضمون في المجال ،
ستعمل بجد من أجله حتى لو
كنت فتاة جديدة أو فتاة عجوز لأن
جميع الفتيات يمكن أن يتعرضن للختان أيضًا على الرغم من
أنك كنت في الفريق لمدة عامين أو ثلاثة
أعوام.  يمكن أن يتم قطعه أيضًا لأنه تم
إعداده ليجعلك تعمل بجدية أكبر
، أصبح الإعداد j مؤثرًا جدًا في
مجتمعات مختلفة بقدر
مجتمع LGBTQ بقدر ما يعرف مصممي الرقص
أن الكثير من الناس يشاهدوننا
ويعرفون أننا أثرنا كثيرًا
يحب الناس رؤية بيونسيه حتى سانت
سييرا تحب بعض حركاتنا ،
إنه متحمس جدًا لأنه يتيح
لك معرفة الأشخاص الكبار مثل هؤلاء الذين
يشاهدونك حقًا ،
لقد صنعنا نجمًا فقط نحن صنعنا
اسمًا لأنفسنا والكثير من الناس يعرفوننا
و  احترمنا منك